here to talk with us about all of our
latest concerns when it comes to the
cover rules epidemiologist dr michael
mina he's the chief science officer at
emed a biotech software service company
that enables authentication of at-home
tests for public health reporting good
morning how are you doing
doing very well
good now we know that you believe
boosters for kids that's the right move
but why is that important right now
yeah that's uh we're seeing pediatric
hospitalizations increase and in a
country like ours that has
an abundance of vaccines as long as we
have decided that they're not going
overseas and that the best place for
those vaccines is here then getting
these
into the into individuals who remain
unboosted and still vulnerable to to
variants like omicron
is is very important right now
you know dr menace so many people are
confused about so many things hopefully
you can sort some things out for us
let's start with the cdc's new isolation
guidelines you have called them reckless
because they do not require a negative
test before you get out of isolation a
lot of people agree with you on that but
the cdc says that they don't ask for the
test because people can still test
positive for up to 12 weeks
and
they can test positive but they're no
longer infectious that's an important
point to make they can test positive but
they're no longer infectious what do you
make of their response to that yeah
that's exactly right that's with pcr and
this is actually an argument that i've
been making
for for almost two years now is that pcr
as a technology is too sensitive and it
can detect people long after they have
been infectious
the appropriate tool in this pandemic to
answer the question do i need to isolate
am i infectious and a risk to my
neighbors
is using a rapid antigen test because it
only stays positive as long as you are
infectious
so
i know mike that the but then you keep
hearing that the antigen tests are not
so reliable those at home antigen tests
are not reliable
well that's a that's been a
misunderstanding because they keep
getting compared to the pcr test and so
if you have a test that will only turn
positive when you are infectious and you
ask somebody to compare to a pcr which
stays positive much longer than you are
infectious then of course you're going
to find a lot of individuals who are
still positive on pcr who are negative
on a rapid home test
and that ends up in the eyes of the fda
and in the eyes of many
scientists who don't necessarily know
what they're looking at it looks like
the rapid test is failing but actually
it's accurate to answer the question
that we're mostly interested in which is
am i a risk to my neighbors and do i
need to isolate that's the first time
i've heard that distinction it's very
interesting very important on this
question of risk of infections
infectiousness if you take that antigen
test at home and you get a line
indicating you're positive but it's a
very faint line is there wiggle room can
you interpret the results in some way
yeah i would say that the the
the line the the interpretation that is
that is rock solid as if the line is
very very dark you know that you have a
lot of replicating virus in you you know
that you're likely very infectious if as
the line becomes very faint
uh you could be at the beginning of your
infection or you could be at the end so
that's where it becomes very important
to have a second test that you can that
you can repeat say 24 or 48 hours later
to see if you're still positive some
people might be on the way up some
people might
be just clearing the virus at that point
so do you think though mike that we need
to take the pcr and the antigen test to
be short to get the results on both
cases
uh no i i don't i think at this point in
the pandemic we know enough about these
tests and the accuracy of the rapid test
that we do not need
to be using the pcr test because
uh because it's so sensitive that we've
now isolated
many many millions and millions of
americans have been isolated just
because they got a swab stuck in their
nose
two weeks after they needed to be
isolated and that led to them getting a
positive on a pcr so we should really
start leaving the pcr test to what it's
best for which is medical
clinical diagnosis by a doctor not in a
hospital or clinic and allow the rapid
test to be used for public health
to know do i need to isolate and be able
to take action that is meant for public
health and not necessarily just for
medicine
are you huddling with the cdc on this
because it's very confusing we get one
message what you're saying and the cdc
is telling us something else
it's very difficult
i've certainly spoken you know to to the
cdc and others and
i think that there continues to be
uh confusion around this in large part
because of how we continue to regulate
the tests at the fda it leads to claims
that are written on the box that aren't
necessarily in line with how americans
actually are wanting to use the test and
that puts the cdc a bit in a box in
terms of what they can recommend for
americans to use these tests for
all right dr michael minna we will keep
following it we appreciate your guidance
on this for today thank you very much